I feel I'm so CL I could take Sweet
Victory I know this life me for me
yeah why would you bet on Goliath when
we got bet David valueing giv values
contagious this world of entrepreneurs
we no value
toomie look what I become
the okay so we got a special guest in
the house we don't normally do a
Wednesday podcast at 3:00 but when a a
friend like this man shows up and he and
I go back I don't know 13 14 2009 I mean
we'll maybe tell you the story a little
bit here hear the history of how this
whole thing got started but
glenbeck uh a big name in media I said
this uh uh two weeks ago three I'll say
it again maybe the best teacher uh in my
opinion number one best teacher when it
comes on to teaching history and
politics on TV W the last 20 years I
don't know if I put anybody ahead in the
teacha been anybody so it's a very small
category but but there's there's a lot
of guys that are great entertainers
which you absolutely are entertaining
there's a lot of guys that are very
smart many of them but they don't know
how to communicate and sometimes you can
go get a message from somebody that's
you know doing a story and then you're
like oh what did he say versus with you
was like 1 2 3 4 I can recite it and
explain it to somebody else that's not
easy to do you did that and I watched
you doing that which was fantastic uh
but rumor has it you know he started off
DJing at the age of 13 so now we don't
know if originally maybe he was trying
to go up against Testo and some of those
we don't know what he was DJing down in
Miami and uh uh and then from there
obviously he's been with CNN success at
CNN success at Fox I mean he's been at
both of them right CNN and fox and then
obviously on media Network The Blaze if
you go to their headquarters in Dallas
it is a behemoth headquarters the former
Paramount right Paramount lot beautiful
lot that you got there fantastic and
then from there you've written so many
books we were talking about a couple of
the books that you and I uh when I was
there at your Museum looking out the
special items that you have at the same
time there's a documentary now available
at the blaze.com which we'll talk talk
about today we'll even show the intro uh
uh the uh uh commercial of it trailer of
it at the end it's called the real story
of colony Rich we'll also talk about it
this is a blaze original production the
link will be below uh both in the chat
as well as the description for you to
find and in the comment section and his
latest book dark future uncovering the
great resets terrifying next phase which
is available on Amazon and it's kind of
perfect timing because you know I'm sure
you had a great time dinner with CLA
Schwab this week I'm sure that was
I love him he's like one kitty cat on
his lap away from being a bond villain
and with that and with that accent like
imagine him telling like a a a good
night a night nighttime story to his kid
yeah never mind never mind the accent
how about the Star Wars suit that he
wear I I mean the guy really I mean it's
Central Casting it's it's almost like
who could we get that would be so
villainous that no one would believe
when you said no the guy's a villain
they'd be like please would he come like
that if he was a villain you will own
nothing and be happy look at how the
world never trust a man that pronounces
the like the with
Z no I don't next you know what the best
part which we'll talk about today is
that a real outfit you know what it
reminds me of it reminds me of that's
pajamas that's the pajamas he we he's
the guy from Dune you know the guy in
Dune the new movie that comes out of the
liquid that's him I think Glenn's right
it's like a villain you remember do you
expect me to talk Goldfinger no I expect
you to die that's him
that's so we got a lot of stories to go
through let me first uh uh set up the
stories and
then we'll give you a campaign update
the most important campaign update going
on with manck between Adam of Vinnie and
Tom it's getting very competitive
craziness Vinnie broke a record
yesterday could I could I ask sure I'm I
mean I have built several uh very large
you know uh Wall Street traded companies
just by doing
advertising how much is it worth for me
to endorse one of you I'm just saying I
mean just saying it ate 25 bucks there's
no telling what Vinnie would do to get
your endorsement Vin that funny as hell
I mean this is a blue card it's not even
a black card or it's a blue cuz he votes
blue and it's still smoking yeah well
when you're at Vinnie's level that's
right he went to Subway at lunch yeah so
here's some stories let me go through
the stories first we're going to talk
about the truth about what happened with
Colin Colony Ridge Texas we'll talk
about that uh there's this conversation
going on about you know what are the red
marks on Trump's hands the goal is to
get to the bottom of this there's
different even who said he thinks it's
syphilis who's the guy that said that
the what's his name James Carville James
Carville I I think it's syis they're
really just looking for anything to put
out there for him not to be able to
shake hands with voters but we'll talk
about that Trump demands total
presidential immunity even for acts that
cross the line I want to get your
thoughts on this that's rolling stone
Nikki Haley uh has a South Carolina
problem her own home state is Trump
County so should she drop out before New
Hampshire because if she loses to Trump
in South Carolina it is going to be
absolutely embarrassing we'll get your
thoughts on that the santis said
something which was kind of interesting
he said he regrets early strategy of
avoiding the media I think somebody kept
saying that for two or three months I
don't know who the guy is maybe we'll
talk little bit that's my favorite story
of the day by I can't wait to react to
that one next NATO warns of allout war
with Russia the next 20 years again
sweet nice gentle message RFK junor RFK
junr sees an opening as more black
voters uh sour on Biden tyranny Trump
vows to block any fed effort to launch
digital currency cbdc is something a lot
of people are concerned about rain Paul
consequences for fouchy should be jail
get your thoughts on it laughable
Heritage Foundation leader bashes World
economic for during Davos event by the
way when he gave the speech it was in
his own language so you have to listen
to the AI version translator he's going
to give the speech in English and you're
going to love what he says to their
faces on why World economic forum is a
problem we'll talk about that cloud
Schwab elections ready folks listen to
this prediction here talking about
that's right elections will soon be a
quaint relic of the past can you imagine
we can make that happen right
away we don't need more and you will
have no question yeah I would just push
this button yeah Biden's doj finally
admits Hunter Hunter Bon's laptop is
real what Chinese media says Taiwan inde
dependence Means War okay now what does
that mean we'll talk about that
representative Elise stefanic gains
ground in Trump running mate race she's
a killer she's she's a beast when she
was talking to Claud and gay and all
those you know so wonderful uh Folks at
Wharton and what's the other school I
there was har yeah Bob igers PID doubles
yeah one good thing about capitalism is
when you're running a business if you do
a shitty job you go out of business or
you don't make money but if you run
Disney M and you fire 7,000 employees
you lay them off and you you produce
bombs after bombs after bombs you get a
salary raise and this raise is not a
small one it's a big one capitalisms
Chang a little bit guys I mean this is
good news for those that don't want to
perform at the highest level JP Morgan
Jamie Diamond also gets a raise his
salary is now roughly $36 million uh we
may have to put him on the neck to make
some money but we'll figure that part
out why India isn't the new China this
is a wsj story and Mark cubin who has
become such a wonderful devout loyal
face of De Dei he's your neighbor MOX oh
but he's a Libertarian he's a
Libertarian he's a Big Ang R guy I
haven't found any libertarian in him but
he's a Liber but he is somewhere in
there he is he box uh Twitter X under
Elon Musk as his little Echo chamber
while defending Dei and then Spurs coach
Greg papovich claims woke ain't that bad
now before we get into these stories
yeah the race for manik real quick uh
here's where it stands guys it's coming
down to the wire Adam 216 this race is
really between Tom and Vinnie right now
Tom's at
377 Vinnie is at
422 it is it is a it is a close race
first to 500 wins the suit okay $2,000
suit this is an internal competition
we're having within here by the way
again man had another record breaking we
guys are asking questions and going out
there asking questions from 5 10 15
different people but last message here
Vinnie do you have a message to your
voters before we wrap up Adam less than
30 seconds ad who's I wrote The Well
Glenn see Glenn is endorsing me so I
just want everybody to know no no no it
says please endorse me I no speak not
speaking English um well for everybody
that's been out there I mean I can't the
I have I've had 120 manx in the past 24
hours I love all of you I can't even
bash Adam's my boy he's kind of you know
he's a shark but he's dead in the water
and Tom I love the guy but as we were
walking in he looked at me and he goes
all puppies are stupid and he doesn't
care about dogs I think he Ked and he
said and you he said he kicked Karina's
dog he kicked the dog you know what he
guys if you love dogs I love the guy but
you can't vote for him he said all dogs
don't go to heaven so if you love dogs
you can't vote for him guys get on my
any question all I need is what 80 you
need 78 to win I need 78 today guys this
can happen by the end of the podcast and
did a shot of Mr Glen can
you the QR code so they can do that Tom
do you have any thoughts any thoughts
well it's really tough to follow um
especially Tom there's a dog here crying
no no it's it's tough to follow because
you know I haven't really
been really interested in this um since
committing to give everything that I win
to charity because cancer
diagnosis and I'm just I've been
preoccupied no in all seriousness thank
you for everybody that's been in on this
manck is all about getting answers to
you you're looking for answers about
business about startups about financing
and thing I love the answers that are
the questions that are coming in because
it says that there's so many people in
America that are trying to do what is
uniquely American use capitalism Liberty
and freedom to Be Your Own Boss and open
something or do something and it's not
people that are out there trying to
spend their kids college fund on doing
something people are like hey I've got a
side hustle going here and here I just
want to optimize a little bit and I am
glad to help and so all joking and
everything aside I love the fact I love
what you've done because you've raised
awareness for a great app Vinnie there's
Tom's Q code so go ahead and do that but
but the truth is Tom you will kill the
dog anyway kick the dog the dog Glen the
was Furious goad I want to say I'm
really proud of what Vinnie's doing
these days he's stepping into the
business World Vin's been a comedian his
whole life he's a changed man I'm very
proud of this guy connect with him there
Tom is the man if you need like we
getting great value by connecting with
Tom on man you know know I joke that I
think he's sort of played with his
currency like China out there and
basically devalued his currency you're
getting a great deal with him but for me
I think we all know Glenn you'll
appreciate this it's a Rigg system they
don't want me to win we all know it I'm
the number one on the app the whole time
but the media the fake news media pbd is
implanting people anyway uh I'm rooting
for my guys necessarily win this one but
I'm going to be the first to a thousand
it's not even think you'll be a first a
th000 I'm up
789 total to Tom 668 he's catch are you
willing to bet on this one and then 525
you willing to bet on this one you bet I
am sir oh who you going to bet you
willing to bet on that you're going to
get 2,000 before time every time we have
a situation what's the first thing to
say say what do you want to say what do
you want to do I'm just listen I'm here
for the long-term Vision say say 10,000
I'm going to be the first how about we
do this for once yes we go to dinner you
pay for dinner for once for once you
have have you ever paid dinner shake you
paid for dinner Shake on it Adam we
going to do this right now what did we
not just have lunch that I paid for the
other day foring for me for once we go
out I pay Val you pay dinner I want to
get
into if Glenn got on right now he he had
a th in two seconds I mean first of all
first of all I mean that was really nice
what you said about the boys but that's
exact opposite of what you said before
we went on
the
trying tell me that media only says the
truth come on let's get into the stories
let's get into the stories let's get
into the stor Adam has perfected it at
dessert at every
dinner run for parking lot let's get
into the stories those are the okay so
let's go through some of these stories
that we got let's start off with a
subtle story and then we'll go to the
big ones the Santa regrets early
strategy of avoiding media Rob if you
have this clip if you can play it he's
being asked I believe it's Hugh huitt
which Glenn you've worked with Hugh
huitt for many years he's asking you
know what could you have done
differently and I respect the fact that
he was being honest go ahead and play
this clip on what the Santa said about
his campaign um you deployed in Iraq
with the seals as their legal adviser
you know they do a hot wash after every
Mission you've been at this for a year
and a half now what errors did you make
that you're willing to say I shouldn't
have done this but I'm going to correct
it going forward I'm going to do well in
March well look I mean I I think that uh
you know we presidential campaigns are a
lot about about media like you I spent a
lot of time on the ground in Iowa and
and it's good and when you meet people
you convert them but there's just so
many voters out there that you got to do
and I came in uh not really doing as
much media um I should have just been
blanketing I should have gone on all the
corporate shows I should have gone on
everything I started doing that as we
got into the end of the summer um and we
did it but we had an opportunity I think
to come out of the gate and do that and
reach of much broader folks now I'm
everywhere I mean I'll show up whever I
committed to do this debate tonight on
WM and ABC in New Hampshire I'm the only
one that was uh that's willing toate
right there so Glen you've been around
for a while what do you think I mean
first of all I like Des santis I I like
him I like him a lot um H but he didn't
have a chance from the Geto as soon as
they indicted trump it was
over there is a uh a Feeling in the
country that guy is getting screwed and
if you like Trump you also like DeSantis
I hated the fact that they were blasting
each other back and forth um but if
you're going to vote for Trump you know
your second guy is probably Dan santis
so with everybody running to Trump he
could have been you know doing naked
interviews with everybody on the planet
and it wouldn't have changed anything so
even a naked interview wouldn't have
I don't think disagree that would have
been have you seen I that would have
been must okay so but let me let me ask
you a question let me ask you a question
so to me I'm I'm all I'm all I'm only
looking at it from a strategy standpoint
right strategy standpoint you know
whenever you lose we've all lost one of
the things you do when you lose you
debrief okay and when you debrief you're
hoping the people that are willing to be
honest with each other in a room that
this doesn't need to be publicly but
when you sit down and honest you have
the convers
and you'll say okay guys number one we
spend way too much money on MAR we spend
way too much money here we spend too
little money here we hired a wrong
Consultants four different times we
chased it in a complete different way
you know like building an insurance
business you can be a great salesperson
but maybe you're a terrible sales leader
so so what helped you become a great
salesperson doesn't help you become a
great sales leader you can be great and
well known in a city cuz you're
connected to the big church and you
connected to the you know whatever game
that's going on or Country Club but
you're not going to be good in a county
you may be good in a county but not in a
state you may be good in a state but not
in a region you may be good in the
region but not nationally running for
president is a very different strategy
than running for governor this is the
Coke Pepsi challenge if you blindfold
people most people say Pepsi is better
than Coke okay but everybody does coke
okay um he's he might be Pepsi to
Trump's Coke people are one they
indicted Donald Trump it was sealed over
yes the the Democrats by persecuting
that guy here's the thing that people I
don't think really understand except
they do internally for them but when
you're looking at the race they don't
really understand the more rocks you
throw at Donald Trump the more rocks I
feel this is what the average person he
I feel hitting me in the head if they're
willing to do this to a guy who is the
first first guy that actually will stand
up for the common man he doesn't give a
flying crap about the Press he doesn't
have the political Consultants that are
going to bend him anyway he's just not
going to do it and he I believe he
actually likes the people in the center
of the country okay he's the only guy
who has been
speaking relatively honest to them I
mean you know you have to there is no
honesty with Donald Trump in some ways
you know you just take it for what it is
but he has he has tried to do his best
in this is the I think what people feel
he's tried to do his best he has made
more changes in significant ways than
probably the last four presidents
combined he's done what he said for the
most part and he gets kicked in the head
and the more they kick him in the head
they put him into jail you're going to
see his numbers go through the roof
where you at on Trump these days by the
way meaning I think in 2016 I don't want
to put words in your I don't want to do
that I don't want to that means we're
moving from the story stay on the no
we're staying on the santis so I want to
wrap this up with the santis and I want
to come back to to get your thoughts on
the santis so do do you Tom do you see
something with the santis when you're
hearing a story like this about him
saying we could have started earlier we
could have done this earlier we could
have done this regardless of whether it
would have helped him or not what do you
think could have been different in the
way he would have campaigned is it
messaging is it listening to Consultants
is it you know who do I take counsel
from who do I take advice from because
am I running for 2024 am I running for
2028 where would you have said CU on day
one time when we started you were team
the santis we when we sat here when we
at the call let's face it and by the way
not just you were team the santis a lot
of people were team the santis right
with this is going to be the guy we can
get behind because the drama doesn't
come with it that's what the DeSantis
party would typically say community
would say what do you see as somebody
that you supported that the momentum
didn't end up happening what do you
think he could have done differently so
first of all um I I look at I listen to
what he just said there in that
interview Hugh hu and I see a head coach
at the microphone in a losing locker
room that's what it sounds like well we
could have done this could have done
that he's trying to keep a brave face at
the very beginning before Trump was
indicted I believe that if he emerged
and ran on his record of all the things
he had done in Florida that he stood up
to co he kept things open he stood up to
Disney and corporate special interest on
the taxing you have to remember what all
those chapters look like and I thought
wow if he takes that to a national stage
that is a very strong cable I'm here to
fix things for you and to make a better
place for you very believably and we had
just seen the sweep election where he
actually with the help of Mayor Suarez
had flipped Dade County and so I said I
felt like that's very cable point two
you asked me I think this was a poorly
run campaign I think it was an
establishment campaign with
establishment consultants and
establishment techniques and he never
got eye to eye with the common guy he
never went on I mean look at why was why
was Obama on Facebook because it reached
voters and it was a new medium and I'm
going to do anything I can to reach
everyone I can because I'm running
against Hillary who's this massive you
know political incumbent Force she's not
the incumbent president but J this
established force and the santis ran an
establishment campaign and didn't take
advantage of podcasts or all the other
things it disappointed me the way the
campaign was run from the beginning and
I agree with you the minute they
indicted Donald Trump even people that
liked D santis are going to come back
and go I can't believe they're doing
this and then all the oxygen comes out
of the room it also becomes inevitable I
because it the temperature is different
in the room than it was at the beginning
of the campaign I knew a lot of people
that were like I'm just so done with
Donald Trump I love Trump I love what he
did but can we move on please it's all
this back and forth circus a lot of
people I knew felt that way they wanted
to santis but as soon as it became
inevitable soon as soon as it starts to
catch up and everybody starts jumping on
and going you know they're screwing him
you kind of feel that way yeah they are
screwing him and it begins to look
inevitable you're on the board you're on
board because you want to win yeah so so
for for uh uh you wanted to I was just
want to say one thing about the STIs the
more and more I look at it it's actually
become completely obvious because the
Republican party has changed
tremendously since 2015 when Trump
endered the race to where it is now it
is no longer the Republican party of old
you know about this probably more than
anyone glenbeck it is now the Maga party
what do I mean we predicted that Ronda
santis was going to do well in preseason
this is my second that's why they play
the game reference we all all pre
preseason this preseason that we all
know what happens in preseason it's all
speculation it's all hypothetical then
they play the game then they actually
have to get up on stage and give
speeches and draw crowds and santis
ain't that dude and it's the smartest
thing Donald Trump trump didn't have to
cuz he already I've seen all the reruns
I've seen all the stuff he so do St
here's what I do know from 2015 2016 to
now the Republican party at this current
moment is not voting for anybody that
doesn't have the it Factor the people
that will go up there and be like
all of you here's the deal why do you
think the Republicans Co last around V
nobody heard of a nine months ago he's
got the it Factor Carrie lake has it as
well nobody has it more than Donald
Trump look at all the losers who are
supposed to be the next people up the
Jeb bushes of the world the Marco Rubio
of the world the Scott Walkers of the
world the the huckabees of the world
none of them have the it Factor Ronda
Sant
is Jeb Bush literally the governor of
Florida 2.0 with zero it you agree with
that kind of I mean his record is so
good he's you know he's a boring guy but
I don't mind boring I'm not I'm not but
the Republican Party does yes um the the
uh the guy who I thought would do better
I didn't think he would be the nominee
but I thought he would do at least twice
as as well as he did as v v ramaswami is
I think he has a very bright future oh
yeah uh I mean he is spoton he's never
confused he's such clear thinker so
rapid doesn't take any crap he is Donald
Trump uh except he's with a photographic
memory that's what he literally with a
photographic memory I'll give my
thoughts on the santis here and by the
way it's so funny Rob can you go to
Twitter so the other day I'm at Mar uh
marago we're shooting a video for an
event that's coming up and then
afterwards on the way back I feel like
getting a hot dog so I get the hot dog
we post this video yesterday and we
showed it to him when we posted this
video I don't want to show you can play
the video again it's just me getting a
hot dog at
7-Eleven see this is a dream when you
make money you get to afford to buy some
high-end type of food and nothing says
more high-end than hot dogs at 7-Eleven
I post this video 7even and then here's
Eric okay so guess what he does VC
retweets it you can pause that Rob VI
retweets it and look what he posts what
does he he retweets his zoom in a little
bit Rob he retweets and says thank you
for coming and don't forget to grab a
slurpie sense of humor and by the way
look how many views it gets go down and
see how many how many .9 milon but PD
tell him why he said that because of the
B of the Babylon B Story by making fun
of the fact that the president Trump's
going to hire him to run the 7-Eleven at
the White House and then someone at the
bottom says it took a Indian and an
Iranian to get people to realize we can
laugh at ourselves get over it right and
move on but this the point I want to
give about the santis okay totally agree
with super talented the SST this this
this the part two things started too
late at the beginning he already thought
it was going to be handed to him they
walked in like they're going to be
presidents his Camp talked to you as if
you're already talking to the
presidential good point campaign I'm
like I would talk to I'm like dude I'm
disgusted with the way I talk to the
team they all spoke to you like they're
they're like this right and a guy wrote
a paper the other day with what paper
was it that he said I was in a room with
26 I don't want name all Spector and
explain the fact what it was like in the
room that he disagreed that's not the
right approach to that's one thing they
felt from day one he's going to be
president number two started too late
number three he didn't promote his book
at all number four which is the one
thing that I think is is a is a big
mistake in his book he gives credit to
Trump I'm convinced he didn't want to
promote the book because in the book he
gives too much credit to Trump and maybe
that changed with the campaign after
they hired a consult they said don't
worry about it let's not promote the
book anymore so you know what happened
here's the last one here's a guy that
tweets for you a couple times endorses
you and helps you become a governor you
win by 34,000 votes second time you win
by one and a half million votes
everybody in your circle says you don't
need Trump anymore I asked him did you
call Trump why would I call Trump I
don't need to call Trump did you call
him and have a visit with him why would
I call him why wouldn't you call him
what do you mean why would I call him
Bas it's basic decency to just go to Mar
Lago and say hey president I appreciate
the tweets I'm thinking about running
great word I would like to get your
blessing and your thoughts what do you
think MH then he is going to be saying
what wow the fact that you came and
asked me that means you're coming from
what kind of an approach a respectful
approach I believe V did that no but but
we're talking the I know that I know and
by the way but notice the difference but
here's the thing though guess who didn't
need to do that vivec didn't need to do
right the Sant Trump's not done anything
for VC directly V has not needed
anything for the sant's called for help
if he would have gone and had that small
little meeting with Trump and he would
have had that could have been a little
bit different so Stephen A Smith when
I'm interviewing him this is six years
ago I'm with him in Connecticut I said
Stephen hey sometimes I wonder when you
guys are trashing people or you're
calling players out some of these guys
are your friends and maybe you don't go
too hard on them Magic Johnson all these
other guys he says I understand what
you're saying he says it's fair I'm good
friends with magic and I'm good friends
with some of these players he says but
sometimes if I'm want to go on on a
player guess what I tell him don't watch
tomorrow's show I'll call him and I'll
tell him tomorrow I'm doing my job which
is calling out players that didn't
perform skip tomorrow's shows cuz I'm
going to call you out Donal Donald Trump
plays hard ball no matter what you say I
fully agree if he's he's there to win I
agree and he will he I mean he'll hug
you you after he's you knowy
orchestrated a car wreck where you and
your family are on fire he'll put a
blanket around you and go hey no hard
feelings either the way if he'll do it
Hillary will just be sure you're dead if
you if you know that if you know that
then the advisers to the STIs and
himself made a wrong move at the
beginning stage didn't go you to above
everybody and this is just meand I just
feel in my heart because I'm watching
this from you know all different angles
I still genuinely don't I think his wife
I think Casey was I don't think he 100%
wanted to run I think somebody was in
his ear his wife was like you can do it
you could run you could go for it and
then he did because if you think about
it Glenn if he just waited if he just
waited and all this is happening with
Trump and just kind of waited you know
supported him and and and chilled out
maybe he could have even been a vice
president selection we don't know yeah
and I will tell you this let's watch
what happens in uh 2028 because I think
if he runs again in 2028 and Trump is
not in the lineup I think his whole
trajectory is different you think so
yeah I I I do more than
Vic it depends on what VI does and this
next couple years I by the way I am so
in line with you on that because truly
so much can change so quickly that no
and especially with a trump because all
you know is Trump could all of a sudden
within three weeks fires Vic Vic could
get a J and then Vic all of a sudden you
know was like Anthony you know scary
muchi is like well the president is this
the president is that and then all of a
sudden he flips on him he like I can't
believe you fired me within 71 whatever
the day was I want to agree with Vinnie
just for one second um you talked about
the wife I don't even think it's
necessarily the wife I'm sure there was
a part of that but it's the handlers
it's a team you know they famously say
that culture beats strategy for
breakfast he had all the strategy we saw
speaking of great teaching Glen Beck we
saw the Whiteboard Approach at the
governor's mansion in Tallahassee yeah
he was nice enough to invite us there we
sat there it was a small room and the
the strategist came out and Pat did he
not just lay out exactly how they're
going to win we're not going to run from
the left because you can't beat from the
left got to beat him from the right
we're going to do this by this there's
going to be 30% of the voters here we
know that Trump's got 33% we can get the
52% like we're like okay let's see what
happens here and then they started the
race and he tripped he fumbled the
literal like Failure to Launch on
Twitter and it's just the the ratings
have been down and down and down and
down and down culture which part whether
you like Trump or not he's part of the
culture and the fabric of America where
the desantis's strategy but na because
in all retrospect if he just waited and
supported Trump imagine that H like and
learn for this next four years of God
willing to let him come in Glenn and
learn how to do that it I mean you I
tell you last week Donald Trump called
me and he
said uh any advice on who I should pick
for vice president who do you think not
that he I mean he's probably calling
everyone but that's great that you're on
that list and so he said who do you
think and I
said I don't know how you're going to
feel about it but this is the day I
think it was the day he trashed vake and
I said v um and he said why do you say
that he said that's the number one
response from everybody I've asked that
question and I he said why do you say
that and I said a he can defend you he's
right in your pocket and while you're
defending this
he's watching your back defending this I
said also um I think he's some of his
ideas are really really good he connects
with the youth which now the latest uh
of 18 to 24 year olds that voted for
Biden they're not voting for Biden but
they won't vote for Donald Trump yet so
you get that lower vote the people that
are excited about hey something fresh
and different and then then in 2028 when
you can no longer run you
continue for another 8 years and you get
the credit for bringing this new fresh
face in I said I I I just think you
become legendary and what did he say to
that well we'll see yeah I actually the
more and more and more I think about it
having spent countless amount of time a
v absolute stud I could see it man I
could see it what do you guys think can
you see that I don't self-identify as
women for the inauguration and be the
first woman I mean that would be the
funniest thing ever what do you think
about
Tulsi I like Tulsa I like her a lot um I
don't think she
helps uh Donald Trump maybe she helps
with the left but you know or with the
Democrats not the left but maybe she
helps um I think knowing Donald Trump uh
especially the Donald Trump of
2016 I think that's the move he'd like
to make I think he well a Democrat
somebody that is not normal I think he
really has a true desire to come
together and I think he believes we can
come together um just like after he
wrecks somebody and then he destroys
them he's like hey buddy how are you you
know you're like I I'm a wreck right now
I'm on
fire if 12% if 12% of America run
elections right and I know people it's
not really 12 more like 40,000 or 70,000
different counties and all this let's
just say the 10 to 12% libertarian
Independents that are like dude I can't
do Trump yes but I you know what
Tulsi really okay so you know how Trump
strategically picked Pence and Pence
brought the Christian yeah it's like
okay that guy is a you know easygoing
guy Christian man boys Indiana you know
all the okay we're not worried about him
but at least at least he's going to be
in his ear to make sure God you know all
this stuff is going to so The
Independents are going to be like look
man I'm I'm telling you I'm sitting this
one out I'm not voting for I'm not
voting for you know the left and I'm not
voting for Trump I want to sit this one
out now they're going to be like whoa
Tulsi interesting so she can bring some
of those ideas maybe Trump's going to be
open to some of the libertarian and
independent ideas strategically speaking
if you're strategist do you think it's
more important to hire someone as a VP
that's going to replace you the next 8
years or do you think it's better to
hire someone as a VP that's going to
help you win today and the people you
need to win today is the independent
voters and the libertarian voters like a
Joe Rogan or an Elon Musk that would be
willing to have her to do a live Elon
Musk does a live with her or spaces with
her it's like hey the vice president and
hey Joe Rogan man those you know what
I'm not going to vote for Trump but she
sells it as look guys I also was like
you at one point but here's where I'm at
let me explain to you why it took me
four years to learn what Biden did etc
etc you see that I I do see that and
that's why I would pick V uh because V
could get on Joe Rogan and just hammer
it hammer it through um but it is the
vice president Anything could happen I
do I I if I were president I would never
pick somebody like Kennedy picked
Johnson Johnson you know Johnson's the
guy that I know but he had to I know but
he's the guy who stopped the Civil
Rights Act in
1959 okay he he was a racist till the
day he died but some say Kenedy wouldn't
have won without Johnson yeah I know I
know yeah so but can you find something
closer to you now maybe maybe Tulsi is
is close but um I think there's enough
conservatives as well that you know when
you hear Trump say things like uh you
know we're not going to cut any of the
entitlements have you seen the debt okay
we're we're not a expanding country you
can take on debt as long as you're
expanding and growing and getting bigger
we're getting smaller yep and you can't
continue to take on this debt and so
when you when you hear things like that
I as a conservative I'm afraid he'll
spend just as much as uh Joe Biden will
and the Republicans will go right along
with him
and if you put somebody in that I don't
know is Rock Solid on basic principles
of our Constitution and I think I think
I'm comfortable enough with Tulsi to be
able to say I think she's pretty solid
on the Bill of Rights and the
Constitution you don't you don't want
you don't want somebody who differs with
you on that let let me ask the question
then let me ask a question maybe in a
different way here so which sport do you
like the most what's your sport like
what what do you watch you're not a
sports guy football I'm not really a
sports guy okay let's just say let's
just say it's football right okay so say
you got somebody that runs a 4240 let's
just say 4340 Adam you can participate
in this one here say person runs a 4340
they're 61 195 PBS and they bench 225 at
the combine 22 times stud fast can jump
by 38 in vertical leap and Coach comes
in
you're like look this guy's a decent
wide receiver he's a seven and a half
but he's not an eight but he just ran a
4 to8 and a 40 okay he can jump 38 Ines
okay he can bench 22 times two plates
the guy's got an incredible personality
great attitude smart as hell great
locker room guy but he's not a full-on
wide receiver in his entire career he's
played wide receiver but he can outrun
everybody what do we do with him as a
team GM you know coach you could say
well let's test him out to see if we can
train him to be a quarterback let's see
if we can put him over here can we put
him at this can we put him at slot can
we put him at this maybe put him pun
return and you work on him for two years
and that's maybe put him kickoff return
because he's so versatile right do you
think Vic is versatile enough for him to
be able to position him in a different
place to still in force oh yeah and do
his part yet think Tulsi in a VP
position I just I you don't see it I
don't see it I I think it's a move that
Donald Trump would like to do because
it's way out of the box I think people
would respond to it I'm just uh I'm just
concerned
about you know Trump is not Mr
Constitution and so I would like Mr or
Mrs constitution on board with Donald
Trump you would like I would like but
but that's not that question though
there's a difference between what you
and I will like versus what's going to
win right so the question is winning
putting T never VI violate your
principles though for something no but
and that's why you get to choose to vote
whatever way you want to vote so you and
I vote the way we want to vote and the
vote could be I'm out I'm in I'll
endorse I'm going to be quiet but I'll
vote right yeah what I'm asking here is
more the LBJ John I'm so glad you
brought that up because that's the
perfect example right and you just want
to make sure this person is not going to
end up killing yeah because that's
neither one of those people are those
types of ambitious crazy wild lynon
Johnson type of people and again I'm
purely speculating but we've all read
the books we know what the mistress sit
on the side so going back to it
percentage odds uh Rob can you run
matter of fact I'm going to run a poll
and I'm going to run who would help
president Trump I'm G to run it on
Twitter as well right now run a poll to
see who would be more helpful for Trump
winning as a VP Tulsi and vivec and I
would be so curious you know what the
audience going to see especially now
because they've heard both sides of the
argument because I think both of them
are rock stars oh I do too I would if if
I were Donald Trump I don't necessarily
know I would name my VP right now but I
would look to Tulsi and I would look to
V and I would say Tulsi you want to be
the uh Secretary of
Defense uh V do you want to be treasury
secretary and I'd put him out on the
road and I'd find these really unique
people remember George Bush he had um
people freaking out that he was you know
just a Playboy and and didn't know what
he was doing and so that's when he got
colen Powell and Dick Cheney and they
went out he put the team in front of
him yeah I think if Donald Trump would
assemble a young vigorous Next
Generation uh team that could go out and
campaign for him and say we're the team
we're the team I think youd change
everything so okay so then I I would say
this last thing and then I want to go to
our sponsor answer real quick so here's
what I would
say I think what's important is you know
the way we built the insurance company I
never forget one day moral and I she I
hired her 14 years ago 13 she used to be
my banker ad WAMU back in the days
remember before Chase it was Wu and WAMU
had all these different Regional places
wow and I brought her in UCLA Grant MBA
smart as hell and one day I say look she
says Pat I want to be a sea so totally
get it I said But first you need to
report to a SE because before you can be
a sea mhm and she says Ah I would like
to report to you for as long as I can I
don't want to report to anybody else I
said listen are you willing to do
whatever it takes to fulfill the vision
is it Vision or is it career which one's
more important she say I believe in a
vision if you believe in division you
got to trust me if you trust me you
report to a seweet executive that's
going to help you become a better
executive then eventually you'll be an
executive she goes under a CFO and he
teaches her a lot he was a phenomenal
very good for then she goes and takes a
different position and she learns under
a different executive while she's
working with me and then eventually she
becomes a president of the insurance
company youngest female president of an
insurance company our size that we're
doing crushing it right and she's done a
great job I think it's very important
for Tulsi and vivec to hear this both of
them are very ambitious both of them are
very smart both of them are very
creative both of them are very they're
calling sorry that no it's your phone at
somewhere I hear something about Taco
well oh do I have it uh behind we just
learned Glen's uh ringtone by the way no
do I have do I bring my it has to be on
you it's it's on you I don't have a
phone so is it your oh is it that is it
your oh it's the iPad it's right there
I'm sorry it's all good Glenn don't
worry Glenn back sorry about that yeah
even Glen Beck makes mistakes sometimes
so here here's here's what I was saying
probably China if by any chance vvec and
Tulsi are listening I think it's
important for both of them who are very
competitive very ambitious very driven
to put AER America before whatever job
they're going to get both of them would
want to be the VP if they're about
America let the administration decide
what job you would have and do you see
that in them you see that see it in both
of them I see because I think both of
them are gangsters yep in my definition
of a gangster I mean a political
gangster which is what you need today to
go against the enemy if you don't have a
political gangster this is not the job
for you I agree agree so this is not
going to be four years of everybody
writing nice things about you the fact
that you're the greatest VP of time
they're going to be trashing you for
four straight years in front of your
family I think this election something
very interesting has happened cuz we we
were all talking about this the VP used
to be what state do I need to carry and
I do a deal making to see if I can add
to my probability of winning then you
went to an Era where the VP was sort of
meaningless but then would get picked on
remember how they tried to undermine
Bush senior with Dan Quail he's a
heartbeat from the presidency and used
to play that card but people didn't see
particular succession risk with with
George W with the Bush senior Herbert
Walker brsh and so they didn't worry
about it today there is more discussion
because you have an what's it going to
be an 82y old and a 78y old running
there's more discussion about succession
saying wow the VP really freaking
matters and what they stand for matters
because it's a platform for the future I
think we're finally at a point after
probably 40 years here that there's some
real honest discussion going on I think
it's healthy for America about what that
VP means and what you where do you think
they would go next to your point I I
think I think you're exactly right and I
think that's the VP that people should
be talking
about we there's no way that Joe Biden
makes it another four years with his
faculties he he'll be you know he'll be
slurping soup out of you know uh uh a a
sippy cup probably the first year in you
say that doesn't happen now I know um
and kamla Harris would be a nightmare I
mean all of our enemies would go are you
kidding me so how are you going to elect
Joe Biden when you know it's going to be
Kamala and he can't replace Kamala yeah
yeah he can't yeah and can you imagine
VC on stage debating how much destroy
3544 votes so far 69% VI 31% Tulsi but
with that being said let's go to our
sponsor rap let's go to the sponsor we
come back for the next
stories so look I've been in the
financial industry since 911 the day
before 911 and I've owned stocks bonds
mutual funds real estate crypto gold you
name it I've owned it but the one thing
that's very important part of my
portfolio all these years is gold I love
having a percentage of my network in
Gold that I have access to in case of
many different things things that's why
we chose to work with our new sponsor
American hardford Gold if you have
retirement funds that you cannot afford
to lose American Harford gold will ship
physical gold or silver directly to your
door also if you have retirement funds
that you can't afford to lose now is the
time to call American Harford gold a
precious metal dealer you can trust they
have the finest products amazing
customer service and a buyback
commitment they've earned a five-star
rating from thousands of reviews and an
A+ from the Better Business Bureau tell
them I send you and they'll send you up
to $5,000 worth of free silver on your
first order so click on the link in the
description or call
866939 6984 again
6984 Tom we are officially live Tom Tom
we're officially live I don't want you
to you know Tom's making a massive bet
on a game fight weekend no no he was
going to say who to fight for Sean
Strickland and I didn't want Tom to get
into fight at the UFC so okay next story
Nikki Haley okay has a South Carolina a
problem her home state is Trump County
this is a Wall Street Journal country
story country I'm sorry a Wall Street uh
uh Trump country yes so here we go Nikki
Ali faces a significant challenge in her
home state of South Carolina where
Donald Trump is the front runner Paul
show Trump leading by 30% 30 points in
South Carolina with Haley garnering
around 20% support South Carolina
represented Nancy M explains South
Carolina likes Nikki Haley but South
Carolina loves Donal what a bad line for
Nikki South Carolina likes Nikki Haley
but South Carolina loves Donald Trump
despite Haley's deep ties to South
Carolina Trump has garnered more
endorsements in the state including
Governor Henry McMaster support Trump
previously won South Carolina in 2016
primary and continues to lead in local
post some allies have urged Florida
Governor Ronda santz another candidate
to drop out of the race but he remains
determined and his campaign argues that
Haley will exit the race after failing
to win her home state Beck Glenn what do
you think about the story uh I think the
people voting for Nikki Haley are not
ones that are going to vote for Ronda
santis or uh Donald Trump so um I I
think those are I mean she's look I like
Nikki she was a tea party person um you
know I was there at the beginning with
her um but I think either her strategy
or her values uh are ay right now the
the thing she's saying about War I I
mean I used to be a guy who used to
believe you know we go in there we kick
some ass blah blah blah I don't believe
that anymore I think we are involved in
everybody's business I think the America
that I thought we were overseas I'm not
sure that I mean you can't torture
people say we're not going to torture a
ghost plan you to Egypt and expect the
Egyptians to think we're the beacon of
Liberty so we've destroyed all of that
um this Ukraine thing is an absolute
nightmare uh I mean you could be looking
of end of days kind of stuff with Iran
and uh Israel I don't want to be
involved in any of these things uh and
Nikki is saying we got to go in there
and we got to take out you know Vladimir
Putin and and and then what then who
replaces him you know that's not our
business and I don't think I'm all for
when a little guy is being beaten up you
know stop bullies and Putin is a very
bad guy he is a stone cold
killer
however um I'm not so sure Ukraine is a
really good friend I mean I mean that's
like I can't be a part of your mafia uh
club I'm going to be a part of this
Mafia Club no thank you Tom yeah uh do
you think she's done do you think like
if if you know and you're an adviser
inside and you're saying Nikki if you
lose South Carol Carolina it's over do
you advise her to leave before New
Hampshire or do New Hampshire get second
place and then step out because by the
way if you do New Hampshire second place
you're kind of saying we have a chance
but if you go to South Carolina you get
destroyed you may permanently be done
for a few years and not just this
election well I think that's what's
about to happen we've been following
these polls for a while and first of all
you just got to look at the raw numbers
the best polling I've team from anywhere
um in South Carolina has the STIs at six
points so if the s leaves and they all
mysteriously go to Haley she is still
five runs behind in the bottom of the
ninth to Donald Trump in South Carolina
and in terms of dog years New Hampshire
is in like 10 minutes yeah right New
Hampshire literally is like in 10
minutes uh and so it's hard to pull
everything of the Machinery out I think
they play it out but she's going to go
down to South Carolina and get destroyed
where she doesn't even have the S
support of the successor Governor from
her own party so it's like go figure
this out Adam what do you think here so
look here here's my predictions right
now here's what's going to happen as of
Tuesday so today's Friday so enjoy the
weekend everybody as of Tuesday Ronda
Sanz is going to finish in a very
distant third he's polling not even
close in New Hampshire he's gonna drop
out within one
week drop out now right now he's gonna
he's gonna enjoy the weekend his last
weekend running for the president Ronda
santis you heard it here and he's going
to drop out as of Tuesday he's got no
path to the presidency whatsoever if he
can continue to somehow raise money and
people just want to still fund a
non-existent campaign he'll take the
money you think he's to wearing
flipflops or he stays He he'll be
flip-flopping all right for sure Haley's
got a chance here it's 49 Trump 34
essentially Haley she's going to give a
a blitz C in New Hampshire she's still
going to finish second and then she's
going to have some decisions to make now
the the South Carolina primary is not
till February 24th she has one month to
see how this how the chips fall if the
santis drops out and somehow she takes
his 10 20% whatever he's at at these
days and she can kind of put no I'm just
saying nationally won't happen wonen I'm
just guys I'm giving you a pathway to
specul I'm just saying speculating I
don't think that she's going to drop out
until the South Carolina race I think
she's going to see it through she's
raised how many how many millions 10
hundred million do plus whatever the
number is she's got the money to last
another month and then Clarity is going
to set in for everybody and it's going
to become abundantly obvious that this
is the Trump party no matter what type
of side deal that Bebe presented or uh
gave his opinion on that Ron was going
to be Nikki's VP I don't none of that
it's not gonna happen this is the Trump
party guys like it or not and everyone
else is dropping out within the next
three days or 30 days there's no way I
mean if you want to be a VP and you're
Ronda santis it isn't Nicki it's Trump
Trump that you should be the VP but he's
not a VP guy he wants to be the leader
the best thing he can do is and and I'm
split on this but if you look at his if
you look at
careers Nikki Haley if she is destroyed
by Donald Trump in her home state she
becomes as effective as Walter Mondale
you want to run again no thank you we've
seen that show she can't win her own
State that's bad but but you're acting
as if she drops out before she actually
plays in the game that that helps her at
all anyway meaning like whether she
drops out or whether she loses we get it
Trump's the guy it's not you
Nikki the difference there's a
difference between your I graciously
drop out sorry for wasting a $100
million and I'm not even going to
participate in the race in my home state
why does that make any sense what looks
what makes you look worse what makes you
look worse like listen I get it why
delay the inevitable let me just
gracefully bow out instead of stop
spending your money stop spending your
donor's money and then then go to a race
that you already lost let's see how she
finishes the New Hampshire we're all in
agreement here saying the same thing
what what is the lifeblood of Elections
money of course that's the that's the
lifeblood of election so if you're Nikki
Haley there is one path from here and
it's Senator it's Senator and you need
to take that donor money and make a war
chest and run for Senate if you want to
continue your political career you've
been Governor you didn't run and you
didn't make it so you have to I think
make nice with people and I think it is
it is in her political career would be
expedient at this hour to say I'm not
going to spend any more money can we War
chest this let me run for Senate on the
weak seat the second
seat that would be great and the people
who I mean it is Trump country the the
people that voted for Donald Trump uh
would vote for Nikki Haley in a
heartbeat uh as a senator and she'd make
a great Senator and it would be good see
here's the problem Ronda Sanz is in and
Nikki Haley you don't want to be that
guy who is just pummeled time and time
again however there is a chance that
Donald Trump doesn't make it to November
and not and I'm not talking about you
know health I'm talking about these
people are serious and and you know I I
I I I would never say this and I have
never said said this before until this
week I started seeing what's coming out
of the
wef and the the things that are coming
out of the mouths now of the diard
leftists that Donald Trump is the most
dangerous man to the entire world now
World freedom I heard a guy from the
intelligence he was head of intelligence
uh in England and he gave an interview
this week and he said Donald Trump being
president is an existential threat to
the United Kingdom joh okay by the way
they said that in 2016 I'm one of the
people Glenn that fell for it and I'm I
was that dude that was like this guy is
going to be the guy I was too okay but
can you at least admit that you were
wrong cuz I admit that oh I admitted
that okay years ago so there we go you
hear that world economic Forum yeah
Trump's not the biggest threat to
democracy big difference between you and
and and the WF people you so so if
you're able to reason you will come to a
good
conclusion this is in life in many times
we will be wrong for a season but if we
are willing if we have the ability to
reason we will eventually come to
conclusion of saying we were wrong okay
these are not reasonable people you're
talking about at wdf you're learning how
to reason
you know Glenn reasons and says yeah I
was wrong I don't think it was going to
be the guy you know and you know
whatever you said it's been years I
think there's a lot of people in America
today that are kind of fallen in your
camp this ain't WF I'll tell you story
right now for WF if you want if you guys
want to go into WF can I just say
something on on that the difference here
with the wef in reasoning between you
and me okay I can admit it I I said on
the air I'll be the first to admit I'm
wrong I hope I'm wrong and I was um the
the w F anybody who will not talk to the
other side is saying to you I have
nothing to learn from you and when you
have that
attitude everything falls apart and
every you become a very dangerous
individual we the people who are going
to save this country are the ones who
will say look I disagree with you but
how did you get there how did you arrive
at that because then we can find a path
towards each other you might teach me
something and go oh crap I didn't even
know that exactly what Jamie Diamond was
saying yesterday the clip that he said
all right you don't agree
what his opening when he says to the to
the CNBC folks okay you believe that why
tell me why asking follow-up questions
because it's your your willingness to
learn and reason and say maybe I don't
have all the answers I'm willing to
learn we've all had to do this in our
day and and and it's it's it's like a
Catch 22 because it's scary in the sense
that where you're talking about
glenworth where some of them are to this
day saying this could be the end of the
world still if Trump comes in but then
it's amazing I think Pat's going to go
on into this story that there's other
people speaking at the WF in front of
all these Maniacs saying hey guys you
guys are effing up cuz this guy killed
it you guys are the problem Pat that's
the one that you're going to let's go to
that not not M herit laughable Heritage
Foundation leader bash's World economic
Forum during Davos Rob if you got this
uh the
video to he is Fant absolutely uh if you
have the clip just play it oh fantastic
just go ahead and play the clip it's
laughable that you would or anyone would
describe Davos as protecting liberal
democracy standing up for it it's it's
it's equally laughable to use the word
dictatorship at Davos and and aim that
at president Trump in fact I think
that's absurd but I'm going to step
aside from that constructive criticism
and instead answer your question yep
Prof and and I'm going to substantive
here president Trump if he's the next
president for that matter I think
whoever the next conservative president
is going to take on the power of the
elites which I mentioned earlier but
there the thing that I want to drive
home here the very reason that I'm here
at Davos is to explain to many people in
this room and who are watching with all
due respect nothing personal but that's
your part of the problem political
Elites tell the average people on three
or four or five issues that the reality
is x when in fact reality is why take
immigration Elites tell us that open
borders and even illegal immigration are
okay the average person tells us in the
United States that both Rob them of the
American way of life they're right
president Trump will take that on on
behalf of the average American Elites
also tell us that Public Safety isn't a
problem in big American cities just
travel to New York or Washington or
Dallas Texas the average person will
tell you that the lack of Public Safety
damages not just the American way of
life but their life president Trump will
take that on thirdly I guess the
favorite at the world economic forum is
climate change Elites tell us that we we
have this existential crisis with
so-called climate change so much so that
climate alarmism is probably the
greatest cause for Mental Health crisis
in the
world the solutions the average person
know B based on climate change are far
worse and more harmful and cost more
human lives
especially in Europe during the time
that you need heating than do the
problems and the problems themselves
fourth two more here Robin the fourth
China the number one adversary not just
to the United States but to Free People
on planet Earth not only do we at at
Davos not say that we give the Chinese
Communist Party a platform count on
President Trump ending that nonsense and
fifth as we sit here another
supranational organization the World
Health Organization is discussing
foisting gender ideology upon the global
South these are practices that are under
review if not being rejected by
countries in northern Europe the new
president especially if it's president
Trump will as you like to say trust the
science he will understand the basic
biological reality of manhood and
Womanhood and do you know why W he is
not because of Retribution not because
he's a dictator but because he has the
power of the American people behind him
and it's connected to Senator Portman's
excellent point that in addition to
needing a vigorous executive we look
forward to having the popular will
inform both the House and Senate in 2025
to pass laws on all of those issues and
right there so Glenn I got a question
for you so question for you is why would
World economic Forum have him give him
the platform and mle to say what so
there are um more elections this year
than any other time in world history
okay it's happening all over the world
is it like 60 no it's 42 42% of people
will be voting voting this year largest
Christian country largest Muslim
countries this year wow so it is it's
happening unlike ever before it's
falling apart on them okay people are
starting to wake up all over the world
and it's falling apart they need to take
some of that um uh stink off of them and
I think by having them and being invited
to go speak you look like well no now
wait a minute you're kind of reasonable
okay there were maybe six people that
because he gave a speech there maybe six
people that clapped occasionally same
thing with Javier just nobody nobody is
supporting in that room nobody's
supporting that but they look open to at
least listening to Common Sense um and
and they're doing it at the same time
they've taken global warming off number
one war not number one threat uh
economics not number one their number
one is Miss and
disinformation okay and they're saying I
mean one of them said it uh I think
yesterday that we control the science we
control the facts that's
ours wow how arrogant is that yeah okay
they haven't changed at all but they're
Changing Faces just like and I'd love to
get your opinion on this I don't you I
saw a story ESG is over bull crap it
will just be called something else MH
that's it verse can I ask you one
question about uh World economic Forum
ENT what was the gentleman who gave that
speech uh Heritage um he's the president
Ser K his name is shout out Kevin
Roberts killed it he's basically saying
you know the old don't believe Your
Lying Eyes nothing to see here approach
the video I was talking about it's
essentially the conversation that we
have in this country was it's Wall
Street versus Main Street we all know
who's in Davos that's Wall Street that's
the big money but when we get to Malay
and this is kind of goes to I I know
that you can weigh in on this you know
there's an article out there in the Wall
Street Journal we can pull that up it
says uh Argentina's melee gives Davos
crowd a spine transplant think about
those words he's basically saying find
your spin Davos and he says this in so
many words talks about the the the
threat of collectivism and I'm going to
throw some terms your way he said the
Western world is in danger of being
co-opted by a vision of the world that
leads to Poverty now however you call
these collectivist variants right and he
starts with the globalists right the
global Elite openly communist fascist
Nazis socialist social Democrats
Democratic Christians neans Progressive
populist nationalist globalist the
global Elites whatever you want to call
them that is a p way to Poverty so you
you've you know about what goes on in
Europe C Davos is in Europe America
Western Liber liberalism totalitarian
socialism Marxism this is your
wheelhouse what do you think about what
mle said and what the absolutely right
this is um you know in America they've
been very very good and they're doing
this to in every country the farmers
they're extremists really have you hung
around the farmers they're not
extremists um in every country they are
painting people that disagree with the
world economic Forum as radicals like
the truck drivers in Canada truck
drivers and they're crazy radicals no
they're not they're driving trucks so so
what they've what they've uh what people
are missing is this isn't about Biden
and Trump that's why they like Trump so
much because they can make him the
Boogey Man and make us hate Democrats
and they hate the Republicans this is
the Elites versus the people all over
the world people this brexit was the
first real punch in the face for the
elites right I don't I want to fly my
flag that doesn't mean I hate other
countries but I want to fly my flag I I
I don't want to be told I have to fly a
rainbow flag I don't hate anybody but
don't tell me what I have to believe
don't tell me that there are 98
different genders that's not scientific
and don't say the science is settled cuz
it's never settled science is never
settled what are you talking about and
so people have been pushed and pushed
and pushed and called so many names
they're starting to stand up and what I
what I think the biggest surprise is
going to come to the Socialist and the
Communists that are all on the streets
they think that's what they was going to
happen they'll be the first to be offed
okay by who by whoever gets the power
okay because the people that are
Democrats that are in on this wef thing
they're all in it for money and power
they're not in it for anything else they
don't believe I don't think they believe
in anything except their own superiority
that other people just don't get it and
I've I want money and power cuz I can I
I'll tell the world how to do it they're
the ranchers we're the sheep or the or
the cows that are kept in a pen and then
slaughtered this is all about
collectivism like like he said and you
said but people think it's about
democracy they think it's about uh the
Republicans versus Democrat no it is
about all of us the majority of the
world saying can you guys stop I just
want to live my life I just want to live
my life and them saying
these people are too stupid they'll
never see it coming it's almost like
it's professors versus the truckers and
the professors say I know what's better
for you they're like listen I know how
to drive a truck but when it comes to
Trump they've kind of almost run out of
all their bullets they've done the
racist thing and the chauvinist thing
and every other racial epithet they
could use for him now it's the threat to
democracy that's why I said earlier or
started to say I worry about the True
Believers of this craziness that will
try to kill him because no other bullets
work against him you're out yeah they've
done the legal stuff they've done the
raids the FBI all of it and it doesn't
work it doesn't work so so uh Glenn are
you because we've talked about this uh
multiple times with all this predictive
programming that they keep shoving in
our faces it's almost as if they're
warning us that's something to come if
they can't cuz I mean I'm and I
genuinely feel that in my heart they're
number one thing if they could they
could take him out if this was a like if
this was JFK time and wasn't more than
one zuder 1,000% they would have tried
to take this guy out so since that can't
be accomplished I'm saying they're
probably still is a window because you
know if there's a will there's a way
what else do you think that they we've
been talking about it what they would
have up their sleeve to keep people from
going to vote would there be an event
would there be something to just not let
this thing happen I think that we are
looking we're living in a time where
we're on borrowed time y um we have had
so many black swans happen to to us and
this it is it amazes me because when I
was in 2006 I was saying storm is coming
this financial thing it doesn't work and
they were all like where did you get
your degree and I'm like I can see it
because I haven't studied what you stud
you believe in the system I can look at
and go these loans make no sense okay
and we were hit in 2008 and I thought
well that will really knock us down
should of but then they changed the
rules of the game but look at what this
system has withstood for almost 20 years
since since 911 we have just been
pounded over and over and over again at
some point that thing is so rickety and
has so many holes in it that a Black
Swan event will collapse it you have
control now of by the radicals of the
top and the streets they don't have the
middle but they have the top and the
streets and this is the way Communists
usually take over countries there's an
event everybody looks at that event or
it causes so much chaos that the bottom
Rises up in the streets causes more
chaos the people in the middle go
somebody's got to make this stop and the
top comes down that's what they have
planned and I think we are a war a a
serious economic shock um a mass killing
a terrorist attack that's when things
will change and I think there is the
possibility if it would be bad enough
there's a possibility that we're just
told like we were with covid stay at
home yep you're not going anywhere stay
at
home I I think we're on the edge of we
could have a dictatorship from either
direction if we're not careful we have
to know the Constitution know our rights
be God loving um God-fearing humble
people that when something goes wrong we
do what we used to do join hands with
one another and say brother I'm here for
you let's we can get through this but
we're in a place to where I think really
bad
people um in other countries know it and
that's why they'll attack and when one
of them attacks they'll all attack cuz
we're so weak mhm we have to be together
as people to be able to survive but I
think we could be seeing a completely
different country by January 1st yeah I
don't I don't know if I disagree but you
know for me earlier today I was having a
conversation with a few guys that were
upstairs they were visiting town and
they said what do you think is going to
happen this year I said it's going to be
chaotic year I've been saying 2024 is
going to be the year of chaos but also
at the same time here's what I told him
I said every once in a while you know if
you believe in God or if you believe in
scripture you know hey it's free will
you know why did that it's free will you
know the choic is on you to choose what
kind of a life why does God allow this
to happen it's free will you know you
get to do whatever you want to do with
your life right free will no problem but
I think every once in a while God sits
there and says okay you guys forgot I'm
around like did you really think I
wasn't around okay all right no problem
you know I'm going to show you the power
that I have and what I'll do every once
in a while I will flex and show my power
I don't know why sometimes weird teams
win championships I don't know why I
don't know why you know Brett far and
Adrien Peterson one of the top five
greatest running backs of all time had
three fumbles that day I don't know how
many fumbles it was Minnesota Vikings
against the New Orleans Saints and Brett
far they should have won that game they
W lost in the last position or two
minutes whatever it was and I'm watching
the game I remember exactly I was at my
sister's house I watch I'm like what the
hell just happened they should have won
the championship but why did new New
Orleans win that year it was the year of
the hurricane and the Saints won why
would Saints krina Katrina you're going
to make them win yeah huh interesting
this
year all the teams lgbtq MLB lgbtq
lgbtq the only team that didn't C to
lgbtq won the World Series seriously the
Texas Rangers you're joking right
no maybe there's certain clues in life
that we have to pay attention to I maybe
maybe he's say something to say listen
if you truly claim you have faith have
faith and Lead if you truly are
concerned about this do your part like
you know pray like it's up to God but
work like it's up to you drive like it's
up to you defend like it's up to you
fight like it's up to you but then pray
like it's up to me okay that's the part
about faith right I don't know why I
think the the level of people that would
have never United with each other who
are from different Sean Strickland I
watch this guy okay this guy's asking
him a question about lgbtq and he says
you would want your son to be this he's
I don't care if I don't have a grandson
he's like you're the FM problem wait a
UFC fighter that grew up with a tough
upbringing that you know the stories
about him and his father he's making
more sense than an educated guy from
Canada that's probably went to the right
University and and this guy's getting
more eyeballs and Logic for no no I
agree with this guy there's something
going on we are finding each other and
when these guys find each other the
enemy fears what is possible and they
don't like people like us waking up
that's where my faith and confidence
comes from because we all have a line
that if you cross we go from being you
know regular people to like Jordan
Peterson says monsters and certain rage
and certain you know person comes out I
think that's the level we are right now
so if they do decide to repeat
themselves and play that game
I don't think this time around
everyone's going to be able to tolerate
I think the the secret uh here is
to um be people that understand good
versus evil understand you know live
your faith um and and be humble I mean I
I think we're just running out of
opportunities to be humble we keep I
mean look at all the time we spend today
talking just about the
election the president's not going to
solve this problem he can help but we
have to solve this problem we have
given we've given common sense and 5,000
years of solid you know uh planning and
and lessons to learn on how societies
work and we've just
allowed elitist intellectuals to tell us
what the truth is when we all know
that's not right and we continue just to
take it and we continue to then go oh
the Fed was wrong oh but wait they're
going to fix it cuz they have this idea
now okayo I was afraid they can't fix it
yeah we are the ones and I love that you
said that because and you nailed it Glen
and this goes to we were at we were at
church on Sunday we uh when you said
it's us it's no left and right it's us
against them and I I wrote this while we
were in church Pat it was no Where
You're vulnerable you know they keep us
all against each other race all what the
vulnerability is fight with the right
weapons you know the sword of the spirit
and the word of God and the last one was
get into the fight we have to fight
because they're go they're fighting and
we have to get involved because what
we're doing is in a spectator sport I
have to tell you that I I am
firmly convinced I mean I am currently
working on things that I can do to keep
my voice
um at least out of the digital ghetto
yeah in the next year um because I I am
convinced these people I mean we're
playing big big ball here you know this
is people die in movies with this kind
of stuff they're they kill them if you
have an event people can disappear they
can easily shut you down I I we are
looking at the loss it has to happen
they're serious about this it has to
happen for them to win they have to sign
Ence powerful voices that disagree with
the wef and the state and there's
several articles look at the one there
were two articles from NBC this week
that were terrifying that were were
talking about how the elites know
science knows the government knows and
there are many people I mean one of the
articles I think it was NBC's article
talks about how the Maga people are just
so vulnerable to miss and
disinformation and so we have to be the
Arbiters of Truth to hell you are okay
vulnerable I know what you guys are
doing there was a story also came out
today about um the University of Rhode
Island they got into bed with the uh
with DHS DHS under Barack Obama came up
with an anti-terror fund and you know if
you can help us find terrorists so the
the University of uh Rhode Island they
wrote a uh paper for a grant and got
into bed with DHS in the paperwork
asking for the grant and the partnership
they say look propaganda isn't bad
propaganda happened in World War I and
World War II and we're in another kind
of war with extremists that believe
Donald Trump is right they were the ones
that were responsible mainly for these
are extremists these are radicals they
were pushing that propaganda out from
the University they're not screwing
around Yep they're they're playing the
win so we have to we have to we have to
too let go to the next door here so Mark
cubin MOX X under Elam musk as his
little Echo chamber defends uh Dei
stance again Mark Cuban criticized El's
comments on diversity equity and
inclusion by saying there are people of
various races ethnicities orientation
Etc that are regularly excluded from
hiring considerations Cuban engag in a
debate on the social media platform X
about Dei noting that it was important
to challenge different viewpoints and
promote diverse perspectives and
discussions he referred to X as elon's L
Echo chamber Cuban defended his decision
to engage in the debate Dei explaining
that he knew he would face criticism but
believed it was essential to reach the
audience on X that needed to hear
alternative perspectives if there was
one light bulb that came on that's a win
back Glenn he is I mean if you don't
believe that these people will come
after you they're coming after Donald
Trump for what he says and believes
they're coming after all of his
supporters they are coming after the guy
who has made a bigger difference on
global warming they're they're claimed
number one thing the guy who's made more
difference in that they're coming after
him why because he thinks that you
should be able to speak your mind and
they immediately try to shut him down
they will do everything everything to
shut him down he was a member they tried
the anti-semitic thing they tried the
girl thing they're trying the drug thing
and I I've said this I can't they know
how many times I've said this we owe
that guy he bought it and lost money
just for me and you to be able to see
and hear everything and make our own
decision did you read his book did you
read there is no way that guy is going
to give up this he will die before
here's a question for you they picked
they picked the wrong let me ask the
question in a different way let me ask
the question a different way so uh uh
Mark cubin says with that in mind 94%
new jobs and S&P 5 and going to the
color sounds about what we ought to
expect it's not evidence of employees
getting to especially Great Links to
higher minorities or discriminating
against white workers or doing anything
other than fishing where the fish are If
the percentage were much lower than 90%
that we would cause for concern the
question I have for you is the following
um he says he believes it's concerning
if more 10% of new jobs in the US go to
white people 60% of the US is white
that's what his concern is here's my
question for you do you think do you
think like do you think Mark is doing
this
because he fears something and he's
defending them do you think he's doing
this because he fully believes this do
you think he's doing this because he
lacks common sense I don't believe he
likes Common Sense do you think he's
doing this because he wants to make
certain people happy why do you think
he's doing this it's not like he needs
money he's he's worth 56 billion what's
he doing this for I don't know him well
enough I've done a couple of interviews
with him and I've been around him a
couple of times so I have very little to
go on but honestly he might be very
smart in a couple things but when it
comes to politics and everything else
the guy's a he really is he justb
he has no idea what he is talking about
he calls himself a Libertarian I'll give
you a libertarian metal detector there's
nothing in his body that would make that
thing beep there is nothing he's I don't
know where he thinks he's libertarian
because he's not and I don't think that
he's saying it for any other reason than
you know it's cool and yeah I I mean I
think everybody should you know be
around with free speech yeah well so do
the people on the left who are currently
now saying shut half the country up they
claim to love it too but when push comes
to shove
I mean I stand for people who say the
worst things the things that I find
absolutely
Dispicable I believe they should be able
to say that Mark and his ilk feel the
exact opposite I'm for you as long as
you're you know reasonable and with me
no that's not the way it works I I I
think he's I think he's very bright in
business I think he's he's a genius in
what he's done recently I think with the
Mavericks but uh I think he's a
politically the thing with Mark Cuban
just to understand is it's very
interesting guy because he is where uh
the intersection of corporate Legacy
Media establishment IDE ideology W uh
NBA social justice movement everything
that kind of that coincides right there
the the the most interesting thing to me
about Mark Cuban is how he he's gone
from
disruptor the most fined NBA owner Tech
Guy like whing around getting fined
every game 20 years later show me more
an establishment figure in pop culture
when it comes to Shark Tank CNBC NBA
yeah but but what's the motive though
that's what I'm like you know right he
said in a in in a text that exchange him
and I had for a couple hours last week
he he said uh uh uh Twitter is an echo
chamber and you know you know I talked
about hey why don't we do a podcast
together if you really want to talk
about this stuff hey this sounds like a
good audience would win I would never
come because you know would be an echo
chamber and if you come over there
you're paneling to your audience I said
you pick the podcast pick the most
liberal podcast you feel safe let me
come you're richer than me you're more
successful than me you're wiser than me
you're older than me what else you I'm
like a underdog I'll come to any Turf
you want to have the conversation in
doesn't want to have the conversation
hasn't responded by the way again in
every education Indiana University exit
multiple times net worth multi-
multibillionaire number of employees
every way you look at it great but when
it comes down to here Tom how do you
miss the mark on something like this
because even on Twitter when he says
Twitter's an echo chamber what
percentage of America is
vaccinated 70% that means what
percentage of Twitter's vaccinated let's
say at least 50% what Echo chamber
you're talking to people that are
probably vaccinated and have taken a
booster so it's just some of these guys
are sitting there saying maybe we were
wrong when we took this year why do you
think he's defending this Dei concept
Tom logically nothing makes sense with
this Dei concept yeah I I think what is
h honestly I think what's happened to
Mark cubin is if you you just look at
the evolution and the longer your kids
around the wrong people the more they
behave like those people you know and I
I think what has happened over time he
has been co- opted into their into their
side you know on China and sneakers and
the NBA you know look at all the
controversies that have come and gone
and what does he do he Towes the line
he's been on Shark Tank um owned by a
major Network for how many seasons and
so how many opportunities you think
there are for things to be said there
but instead he's co-opted into that I
just think he is slowly like a frog
boiled in the pot and has been co-opted
into it we don't appreciate how hard it
well maybe you do to work for a major
national network and you've worked for a
few ownerships of um radio I was fired
from ABC Network I was fired from ABC on
day number one yes my first
day what happened I hope you're in a
radio hall of fame for
that uh I was hired um Diane Sawyer at
the time uh she came over uh to my
office and she's like you know you are a
game changer I was on CNN you were a
game changer and uh I think you can help
I'm going to start doing nighttime she
was during the day she said I I I'm
really very influential I'm going to
start doing the nighttime news which she
eventually did and you should take over
Nightline together we could change news
I said okay I'm in and so she had this
whole plan and uh she got me in and day
number one care
went to the mouse house and said if you
allow this bigot we will protest and we
will shut down Disney and you're part of
it Mouse and nobody hurts the mouse
nobody hurts the mouse day number one
I'm out wow day number one this is what
show this is 200 maybe n or 10 MH
something wow 2009 or 10 when this
happened actually it might have been
earlier than that cuz I was at
CNN and I I I I just I'll never forget
it I'll never forget it she was on the
air with me on the day they announced
she's on the air and she's like this the
most brilliant guy he is just so great
and he's just got so many creative ideas
we're just going to change television
she couldn't say enough my wife was like
can you tell Diane Sawyer to stop
calling you okay uh and the very next
day nothing can't get her on the phone
can't don't hear from her it takes about
6 months and I'm starting to kick up
some storm cuz I don't really care I'm
getting paid from ABC but you know I
think people should know what happened
and so I start talking about it on the
air and she calls me and she says I
think we need to have lunch it was it
was the weirdest lunch ever we sat there
and she brought up my religion and that
means that you must hate women and all
of these and I'm like what the hell you
are a coward you are a coward yeah and
she's a big name in news I mean pull her
up I mean she's other than Barbara
Walters was there a than arbar Walters
is there a bigger name in news than
Diane Sawyer back in the day no massive
no she was the name it wasn't like just
some obscure local journalist this was
the lady yep yeah yeah look if we hop in
the DeLorean and go back to the future
the days of Ro Ro you know Walter conry
and you can see what what happened there
and and that there was a neutrality in
news there was a genuine desire to keep
the news at some level of unbias and it
just kind of slowly election by election
it just kind of rolled out the window
and now you're somebody like uh you know
Mark cubin I just think he's been boiled
like a frog in the pot and that's where
come and he gives you have a great
example and you know so like I say if
you hop into DeLorean you drive real
fast although you know that could be a
problem
too and um
you that's what's happened to him and it
doesn't make rational sense but he's so
in inculcated in all of the media thing
that he doesn't look like it makes
rational sense but he's been just boiled
and that's who he is and have you ever
known anybody who should know better I
mean the Diane Sawyer Story come on
you're smarter than this you know what's
going on however I'm happy I'm fine I
don't want any trouble in my life life
I'm not questioning and I think that's
where Mark Cuban is he's nobody you know
I I have I have had my name called I
mean I've just they've tried to destroy
me for years um and that just pisses me
off and makes me fight harder um but I
don't want that I'd much rather be with
the cool kids I've never been with cool
kids
but I find myself here and if I wasn't
driven by true belief in God and that we
all are born for a reason and a time I
would have given up a long time ago if
not given up if I just would have play
when Roger alss talked to me um uh
towards the end of my time at Fox he
said to me you know what your problem is
and I said now what and he said you
won't play the game and I said because
some of us don't believe it is a game we
actually believe what we say wow wow
that's powerful respect and and and
Rogers had a lot of good com I hear a
lot of Rogers stories from people that
he helped developed and talent and all
this stuff and everybody has a different
story they tell yeah that's what
everybody says let's go to Bob Iger
since you brought up Disney Bob iger's
paid doubled in 2023 as Disney laid off
7,000 employees released box office
bombs back to back to back Bob Iger saw
his compensation more than double last
year uh uh as the once great Studio
continues to struggle financially and
creatively Bob Iger earned
$31.6 million in total comp for the
fiscal year that ended in September up
from 15 million in 2022 his 2023 pay
included a salary uh of $865,000 stock
awards of $16.1 million and $10 million
in stock options Awards $2.1 million in
performance-based uh compensation $2.48
million in other pay Iger pay increase
came as Disney experienced Another Bad
Year company laid off 7,000 employees
worldwide and is planning an additional
$2 billion in Cuts Disney streaming
services have lost billions of dollars
as the company splurges on content that
is having a difficult time connecting
with the audience Tom you hear a story
like this how do you process this Tom I
process it this way first of all there's
not this is this is a inflammatory
headline story oh you can't believe it
you can't believe it the only thing that
we have to remember on this is Bob Iger
was desperately sought to come back and
this is an employment contract that has
these things in it on how they're going
to pay him what part of it was
performance-based of the 31.6 2.1
million that's a lot of money but 2.1
million is Performance Based I'd be
willing to bet that everything that
we've seen here we know the base salary
is in there and we know where the stock
awards are so basically this was I think
in the contract that he signed when they
said Bob please come back we need you
for 36 months man yeah so it's not based
on what he did this year is it just a
comp said you're second you're going to
make XYZ amount of money that's exactly
right 2.1 in performance-based
compensation how do we know that wasn't
supposed to be 20.1 and that the reason
it's only 2.1 is because there was the
bombs and the problems that rat that's
dead that's his that's that's Disney
right there that's a analogy of what
Disney is Right Mouse is dead but isn't
it isn't a mouse is dead what a crazy
that's that there but but you know I
love about that that entire story how
much money did Disney lose then last
what it say 200 how much because what
they're having a problem with their
content because the people that you're
talking about us this us against them
we're not buying that crap so yeah I I I
I have to tell you I don't know anything
really about the law but I I if I were a
shareholder I would want a class action
suit against Bob Iger because Bob is the
reason it started you hire when I was
again when I was at ABC your name tags
this is again but 2008 your name tag had
the Rainbow on it okay everybody's
everybody's okay had a rainbow on it and
that was just to support
lgbtq okay fine fine but to me that said
the company is ideal logical and it is
it will protect its own
ideology a news company should not have
ideology other than the pursuit of Truth
let the chips fall where they may
Disney you know it's very hard to you
know run a creative company and not have
people that live different Lifestyles
that's fine but you cannot build your
company and have the people that have a
different lifestyle than your
audience telling I've we're going to
tell our story no you are here to tell
the story that our audiences want to
hear the number one that was the number
one brand maybe of all time and their
brand was will your children are safe
with us yes and they flushed that down
the toilet without any regard for the
fact that it took him almost a hundred
years to build that brand how is how is
that not something actionable for people
who had shares in the uh in the country
they just took it and turned it off and
quite honestly I think the only thing
you can do to fix it I think it's so
beyond fixing is you have to fire every
you have to shut the whole thing down
and turn it back on with new ownership
that actually understands cuz I don't
know how you save that now I want to
show you something I want to show you
some numbers here Tom check this out Rob
can you pull up what I just sent to you
real quick so this is Disney's valuation
in the last whatever 20 years right and
so when you look at the Disney stock
it's important to know this and it's
important to know a timeline on whatever
you know job responsibility when he
retired when he returned so check this
out this is Disney's valuation go up uh
to the bottom where it shows year by
year by year go a little overow go yeah
right there okay zoom in a little bit if
you can okay so 2024 valuation is what
170 billion 2023 165 billion 2022 158
billion it's it dropped 43% 44% from
2021 at 281 down to 158 billion and 2020
it's 328 billion 2019 257 billion
208 164 and then you have 162 so from
2015 to day 10 years the stock is
flat 2015 to today the stock is flat now
these are important events to know do
you know what day Disney plus came out
when it blew up Disney it was Disney
plus came out November 12 2019 look what
happens to the stock wow 60% is up look
at 2020 what happens in 2020 covid every
streaming company blows up Zoom
valuation goes skyrocketing net every
body is blown up with streaming in 2020
because everybody was locked in they're
watching homes now watch this Bob Iger
when does he retire the first time
around when does he retire he retires
December 2021 okay which is a phenomenal
time to retire you've done a great job
he retires Bob Sheek is doing what he's
doing when does he return December of
2020 uh he returns November 20th of 2020
so look at from November 20th 2020 it's
what 1508 bill ion the company's not
changed anything but what has he done
he's fired 7,000 people which means Opex
has gone lower now when did he become
the CEO and the chairman of the company
October of 2005 can you go down to
October in 2005 so when he came in $47
billion as the CEO he took it from 47
billion in 2005 20 years later it's
worth what $170 billion he's probably
the biggest dealmaker in the business
we've seen he has a lot of Victories but
one him coming back is the same thing
when a guy that's got a great career
comes back and ruins his numbers and it
looks pretty bad and the averages drop
and all this other stuff but also at the
same time with Disney the problem is the
following Glenn when they make a movie
or a catalog of movies did they produce
that thing three years ago four years
ago which means you have to sit there
and know if today we have a great idea
for a movie that we're changing our
philosophy the market is not going to
know about it for 3 to 5 years so
turning around those types of things
takes a long time but they're not
they're not taking it on they can't
their their entire employee roster now
is full of radicals you can't just say
oh you know I know you said we're going
to change your kids yeah uh but we don't
want you to do that you're still staying
in your office and you can keep your
team how many those 7,000 people getting
fired you think are on the left well I
think almost
everybody at Disney right like 98% they
give money to the Democrats 97 98% I
maybe I'm off by a couple percent but
okay so most of them are how much of
that firing you think Tom is just
decreasing Opex versus how much of that
firing is like look guys we got to go
back to who loves Disney who knows who
the customer is who you don't think
that's the focus you think it's just
decreasing OB Iger is the problem he is
the
problem
period a lot of people around Hollywood
agree with that so to answer your
question Pat I think this is a this was
a CFO firing you know this is basically
not firing the CFO this is like they're
looking to take cost out of the business
now I think it was a legitimate thing
they're they're say cost here cost here
cost here but it's I don't think it's
it's a cleansing I think it's just where
can we squeeze and remove costs from the
business it's not where can we correct
ideology where is this an opportunity to
shift the ideology or shift the business
it's just how do we squeeze costs out of
the business the rest of Hollywood has
been mocking Disney for the last two
years if you look carefully you look at
what people say now there's Bob in his
Circle and everything but the Hollywood
reporters been questioning the results
of Disney the Hollywood there's a lot of
people that are rational about the
business that have been questioning this
shoot South Park did an incredible
episode on Kathleen Kennedy and she
spent the next four weeks trying to get
that pulled with every muscle in her in
her I haven't seen it what's it about oh
South Park destroy they make it look
like that Kathleen Kennedy is in the
process of owning uh Bob Iger and she's
taking and remaking every Disney film to
remove any of the original tenants and
to insert all of the all the we show it
everyone every well I don't know but
everyone one in South Park has become uh
lesbian uh you know gay black
Andy and you know becomes a black woman
gay black woman yeah I mean it's really
really pointed in great and when did
this come out this this is this year
yeah three months ago yeah that's the
South Park kids that have now been
replaced by them and anyway and the the
episode culminates in Bob iger's office
where a cowering Bob Iger is listening
to Kathleen Kennedy lecture him about
what they're going to doing uh don't you
think the shareholders and what we
should do no Bob we're doing this okay
Kent you're company and so it's it's
heavy but point is this is just one part
Hollywood is pointing at Disney and
saying this thing's out of control when
you even have some by the way
Hollywood's not going conservative and
they're not getting not getting their
act together but what you do see is
Islands in the Stream are saying
they're nuts well look at look at all of
the money they own the greatest stories
that have been told in I mean
America and now Disney is the source of
uh the Star Wars franchise the
superheroes you know the greatest family
cartoons and they have destroyed each of
them one by one it's they keep them they
bought the entire Fox Library which is
with a mountain of debt Bob Iger signed
the check no mean ex me signed the
papers for the mountain of debt which is
part of the problem they assimilated all
of Hulu they owe Comcast an ungodly sum
this year for Hulu that they're not
going to be able to write that check so
they're teetering on this mountain of
debt and obligations assembling as you
correctly point out the greatest catalog
in history and what was the biggest
movie Money Maker last year by far of
last year sound of freed sound of
Freedom sound of Freedom you know who
owned it Disney and they refused to
release it oh yeah they bought it in the
catalog it was sitting there they
wouldn't do it they finally made a deal
with Angel Studios and Angel Studios
released it what what would what would
be the what would I asked this before
what would be a reason for you not to
show a movie that is pointing out that
children are getting sex traffic like
nothing wrong where's the motive of
buying it and not showing it to
everybody why why why would you do that
well they bought it in a cat so it's not
like they went out and bought that one
um but they I think you could say one of
two things you know uh there's a lot of
people that don't think that that's so
bad anymore that you can have children
and use them for sex uh and the other is
um they just they don't think they think
everybody thinks like them Y and they
don't think this is a problem and so
it's not going to do well yeah at the
same time they're making the same kind
of decision saying No this is what
people want and they're bombing cuz it's
not what people want yeah like
Cinderella was it Cinderella with that
actress Snow White she's like that guy's
a stalker we're changing the story to
make it why are you changing the story
what are you talking about you were
asleep and poisoned young lady he came
and kissed you and now you're alive but
he's a graper it's like you'd be dead
yeah Shane thank you so I I'll just say
one thing about what we see on the on
the back end or the external part of it
but then there's also the internal part
of it the employees and the culture so
we're seeing the back end of it when the
movie comes out we're like yeah I don't
this is kind of weird and the patriarchy
stuff with Barbie or whatever the
Hollywood movies comes out and you know
the the the the Dei and the ESG but but
it's interesting because I have
conversations with certain people who
are on the internal on these types of
organizations not necessarily Disney but
these types of companies and like a lot
of them work remote right we know that
work from remote and I'll say well
what's it like like what's the what the
conversation's like and they say a lot
of times when they get on the zoom it's
it's mandatory or obligatory to put your
pronouns in your bio or how you identify
I'm like what do you mean they're like
well you've never had to do that I'm
like no it's not a thing do here nobody
but they literally have to say like she
her he hey the them whatever the hell it
is right
insert you know what a gay horse is he
but it's like but that's how you change
the situation we only see it on the back
end over here but internally can you
imagine if any of us were on these zooms
we like oh do you identify I was like I
don't know dude like what what's
happening right now but a lot of the
people will go along because if they're
not in that world they're an ally and
you know the whole Ally sit yeah exactly
let's go to the next story here uh uh
and then we'll wrap up with uh uh Colony
Ridge Last Story here um Chinese media
Taiwan Independence Means War okay so I
mean obviously you don't want to hear
that but let's see what they have to say
here who jiin former editor of Chinese
state run Global times has raised
concerns about the potential for war if
Taiwan seeks Independence under
President William liing te who asserted
Taiwan Independence Means War and the
red line drawn by the Chinese Mainland
is clear he also questioned Li's
leadership stating that Li might not be
more radical than his pre uh predecessor
H Hugh pointed out the significance of
the United States in Taiwan issue noting
that President Joe Biden publicly stated
the US does not support Taiwan
Independence but aims to contain China
uh through this matter he speculated
that if former president Donald Trump
were to be reelected it could introduce
new uncertainties in the Taiwan uh
Straits due to his presumed stronger
stance against against China Glenn
thoughts uh a couple of things first of
all um China will take um uh Taiwan and
they'll take it when the United States
is too busy concentrating on something
else um we don't have the ability
luckily they don't have the ships to
land the forces right yet they will in a
couple of years but they could just I
mean they they could take it uh if we're
not paying attention we don't have the
ability to fight um in in ch fight China
at this point we just don't have the
assets we don't have the supply chain
stretched that far the one thing that
you have to pay attention to on Taiwan
is the chips that they make these are
the highest end chips these are the ones
for the
supercomputers they have the ability in
Taiwan to make chips that nobody else
makes if China gets those chip factories
we lose the whole world loses to China
and everybody knows that especially
China I've talked to people who um you
know have experience at the NSA and uh
Department of Defense who have been in
conversations about China and um it blew
my mind when they said this their best
hope is that if China starts to invest
or take Taiwan that we will blow up all
of the chip plants oh wow okay that's
like seriously discussed maybe we should
just blow all the chip plants up so they
can't have it either how much is that as
a threat I'm just kind of like talking
just saying let me I'm going kick
your ass you think it's like kind of
like that because have you but have you
read that have you heard that anywhere
no I mean I read that I remember when
that story came out but you know what
would happen if they did that that the
supply of the semiconductor chips that
we need that the world relies on with
you know uh Taiwan price of used cars
would go to the roof price of new cars
everything would go to the roof cuz God
knows how each car that you buy has
anywhere between 1,500 to 3,000 chips a
lot of those chips depending on the
quality so I don't know if they're
talking smack or if they're being real
about it do you not think that there are
I mean I think these are these are early
20th century progressives many of them
they are
anti-human they are
anti-modernity I I don't think that
there is a problem with some there's
some really scary people that would
really mean okay so yeah all right so
Millions would die but this goal would
be accomplished but yes we'll starve
people on this but we won't be eating
meat and it'll be good for the planet I
I think these people are so antihuman
that those kinds of things you know the
reason why we we lasted the cold war is
because of the movie The Day After
Ronald Reagan watched it ABC gave him a
videotape of it he watched it in the
Oval Office gorbachov watched it and
they both changed in Reagan's diary he
said dear Lord we cannot let this happen
so you had two reasonable people who
said no matter what too many people will
die we cannot do that we coming to a
place to where some of the people who
have
power they don't think that way what we
think is
Unthinkable they do because it would be
good for the planet it would be good we
are expendable we're sheep do you think
China is China first how do you think X
looks at World economic Forum as a
useful idiot oh yeah okay so China looks
a you know World econom we're going to
use these guys we're going to buy them
out and give them some favors and
they're going to do whatever we want
them to do that's how they view them
okay do you think China uh uh X is
excited about a trump candidacy or he
would much rather prefer it be a Nome or
a Michelle or somebody on the left or or
or a Biden well definitely a Biden
because he's bought and paid for so yeah
Biden would be his choice why do you
think he why do you think China if Biden
under Biden you know let's just say you
know Putin took advantage of it went
after Ukraine and you know NATO is
saying we may have a war for 20 years or
whatever they're talking about here or
hey you know Hamas attacks Israel all
right so that took place and then
there's that war going on which has been
so divisive worldwide Afghanistan we
leave you know God knows how much
weapons we left behind uh and the Air
Force Base that China now
has yes and why do you think if China is
so bad and evil which I believe they are
yeah why do you think they haven't yet
attacked and done anything to Taiwan
what are they waiting for they're
playing the long game they they can't
they don't have the ships to do it I
don't think I I don't think that China
wants to have a war China would rather
just take it and they're such long-term
thinkers that okay wait five years the
United States is falling apart they're
not going to be able to do it we'll have
everything we need to be able to do it
maybe in 5 years I mean look at Hong
Kong look at Hong Kong they didn't do
anything until we were distracted and
then all those people went
away and nobody even talks about Hong
Kong at this point right and if you
would have if they would have acted when
everybody were like well they're not
they're backing down they would have had
the whole world in their face they
win different thoughts do you have a
different view than What Glenn said not
really um except one thing that I'll add
to it and he he didn't bring up the word
but I I think he's probably going to
perk up when I say it is sometimes they
look really really crazy and then they
understand some of these outcomes but
you have to remember there is a huge
plank in their in their platform is WF
and the global thinkers about
depopulation being good so right so if
there is Calamity and everything that
takes out two billion people over a span
of six years that's okay because it's
actually healing to the Earth CU we're
stressing the Earth we don't need this
many people and all like that now
military strategy would say that the
best day to go after Taiwan is August
21st of this year if that's the last day
of the democratic uh convention in
Chicago if Biden is the candidate
because they're like okay it's still
Biden we got to do it now because if
Trump wins we can't do it y you know
because Trump's going to expand the base
there and say I dare you it's very
simple all we have to do is expand the
military president in Taiwan we already
have and say I freaking dare you right
that's
it but to Glenn's Point uh Rob the
chart this is exactly what you were
referencing the blue is taiwan's market
share of the world high-end chips geez
look at that it would be a terrible
disaster no no that's why by the way
this is from CNBC this isn't from some
this is four years ago right and you and
you want to you you want to understand
uh
national interests is it in our national
interest that's pretty clear oh it's
it's 100% National interest and
international interest and China's
interest and a lot of people's interest
y this is this this will uh you know I
remember when uh uh during covid used
cars were selling for more than new cars
you're like wait a minute what's going
on remember you can't find a watch you
couldn't find anything Ford couldn't
ship F-150 tickets they had a uh my car
was worth $20,000 the Ford F-150 $2,000
more a year and a half a year after I
bought it like what do you mean by this
he is like we'll pay 20 more people are
buying a premium for it I'm like you're
kidding me no so it was it was a very
weird time at that time but I want to go
to The Last Story here before wrap up is
the truth about Colony reach Colony Rich
Texas now Glenn before we get into it do
you want to set it up before we play the
trailer here for this documentary so
there was there two stories that came
out one was from the daily wire uh and
one was from the New York Post
and they say that this was run by the
drug
cartels um that it's going to be the
biggest population in one place of uh
illegal immigrants they don't speak
English um that it's a hor show so when
we went down uh that's what I was
expecting what I found was not that but
I think just as bad and this is this
this
gigantic goes on for Miles this gigantic
uh plot of land where developers are
selling it legally to um illegals for I
think it's a $100 down you can buy a
house what okay $100 down 15 uh not a
house land uh and it's uh I think 15% or
14% interest okay um and people are
buying it 30% default rate
30% so they default because they're
carrying the note you're in default I
take your land back I resell it this is
a money maker like you can't believe you
cannot import 10 million people into a
country and not have communities like
this this is the future of America if we
don't wake up if you ever been to Brazil
you go to Rio nice houses right out out
of the gate poverty like you've never
seen right that's what's coming to
America we are becoming a third world
nation and this is the canary in the
coal mine Rob if you got the clip to
play it uh thereo if you want to make
you big run let uh I think that's
commercial not that guy he's going to
talk about your poop yeah about your
poop really okay developer and I mean it
was honestly I thought I was being
punked it was like do you remember when
what's his name used to play this on
Saturday Night Live the 60 Minutes guy
and he'd be sweaty and remember it was
like that sitting with this guy um and I
said to him uh as we went for a tour I
said have you ever seen It's a Wonderful
Life and he immediately said I'm not Mr
Potter oh wow he knows who he is yep wow
and it is Potterville but you are
looking at a place that the the school
brand new giant schools are already
putting trailers out and there's no tax
base okay these are poor people and
we're just importing them the the uh
crime is off the charts and the
developer was like well that's because
the
county the the county hasn't changed
except for this um and the most
disturbing thing is our Republican
Governor uh took $1.5 million from the
developer's brother uh in can campaign
contributions we called him we wrote to
him snail mail even just in case they so
who Governor Abbott Governor Abbott no
response I I can usually get a call back
from
somebody no response and we tried for
probably five weeks to get I'll fly to
you I'll do it at any hour any time any
place I just have a few questions when I
asked the developer I said uh I said
what are the what do people you know why
would you why would you spend $1.4
million to the governor he's like well
you know we really think he's great and
I said so do I but I haven't given him
1.4 what are you getting for that 1.4
and he said you don't get things from
politicians like that and I just looked
at him and he went okay all right okay
yeah I mean but he didn't tell you no he
didn't tell me but so what do you think
he's getting if if he were to get
anything what would he get from a
governor Abbott uh he's getting I think
um call off the dogs I don't think he's
doing anything illegal okay but he's
doing a lot of imoral stuff really bad
he's he's really really I think a really
bad kind of
businessman um but I don't think he's
doing anything illegal but how can the
governor who has such a problem now this
is a red deeply Red County it won't be
for long it the the migrant if you want
to call it that the migrant population
already
dwarfs the people that used to live
there okay this is about flipping Texas
once these and once people understand
what he's doing there are all kinds of
shady businessmen all over the country I
mean we've we have grown our population
the size of one Arkansas in four
years well that's not no not Arkansas
Alabama one
Alabama you can't keep this up without
completely changing the financial alone
the financial situation of the country
and Texas would be the first round draft
pick for the Democrats to flip oh they
would love Texas before Florida by the
way oh you flip Texas and you're done
never see a republic again well that's
the entire point of a completely open
border with no answers no accountability
for Myers nobody everybody's using the
whole humanitarian thing that is so bril
because that's exactly what the point is
and now you're seeing it because they're
building cities and like you said that's
going to flip why else would they have
the Border completely open why that's it
right there you know that there there's
a couple of things that have um been in
play for a very long time that people
don't understand one is the cloward and
Piven collapse Theory you overwhelm the
system you use the system and pit it
against itself you overwhelm it and you
collapse the economy you collapse the
government because of of debt that's uh
that's in play the the other thing is
again all of it is about chaos and
collapse you know the the Red Cross
Doctors Without border
they are handing out Maps we have them
handing out maps to people in um Middle
America and South America they're
handing them out with the train
schedules the uh stops where you'll be
welcome the maps how to go where to go
to cross into the United States the red
cross the United Nations and Doctors
Without Borders those are three that we
can verify cuz we have the document we
have what they're handing out this is an
organized plot to collapse the United
States when we go into real trouble I
mean look at what came out today with
with Denver they can't afford the
hospitals when we go into real trouble
and we hit real economic hard times and
you've got rationing and everything else
and you have 10 million people that are
already
disaster do you think things are going
to get better or worse and how long does
it take before people say you know what
this was my land in the first place and
I don't mean Americans I mean
everybody's been groomed to say America
stole this land how long before
Californians start to hear you know what
this is Mexican land this is foreign
land you stole it from us you you
introduce real poverty and
despair we have we're sitting on a
powder keg a powder keg we got to humble
oursel and return to solid
principles that's powerful then I you
know right now we you saw last week that
this the debate going back and forth
online how you know we have more
potential migrants IM illegal immigrants
coming here in one term than the
previous three terms combined they're
projecting
12.99 Mill million illegal immigrants
coming through here did you did you see
what the world economic Forum said
Canada now imagine being a Canadian
Canada has the most open space the most
resources for farming and to take people
and water and they're suggesting that in
the next few years the next decade that
they should take on 35 million
immigrants to cross our board by the way
the population of Canada is
million and you know what by the way you
know what let's send a bunch of buses
over to Canada help us
out we contribute it to Justin anyways
we're going to put the link below Rob
for the documentary if you can as well
as the link to uh Glenn's book to be
able to order as well Rob if you can put
that dark future on covering the great
resets terrifying next phase available
on Amazon just came out a few months ago
both will be there Glenn it's been a
blast having you on great this was
phenomenal looking forward to GL Glenn
touched my arm that's a visual of
endorsement for the Man app you guys saw
that's absolutely true in a world that
tells Li 59 man away from Vinnie Vin is
I have code happen by midnight ladies I
have to address my constituents guys
please get on my neck we're doing this
tonight I'm staying up all night I'll
respond to everybody Vinnie doesn't hang
out with me on the weekends anyway so I
believe you thank you everybody have a
great weekend bye- bye bye bye
back